olá meu nome é eu sou dono 5º ano e vim
falar pra vocês sobre a economia de
consumo
eu escolhi esse tema porque é importante
para a humanidade ela só pensei em
comprar comprar comprar sempre há coisas
mais caras e as coisas cara nem sempre
são as melhores
quem me ajudou nessa apresentação foi
meu tio que o franco jerry é graduado em
ciências econômicas pela faculdade
insper antigo ibmec o que é economia
economia é o processo desde a fabricação
até o venda ou troca da mercadoria
existem três tipos de economia as trocas
ou escambo que índios e portugueses
fácil
vou dar um exemplo eu tenho uma fazenda
de arroz
vocês têm uma fazenda de maçã ea gente
troca um quilo de arroz por um quilo de
moça e de subsistência autossuficiente
que pessoas mesmo produzindo que elas
mesmas precisam é ser uma boa opção para
a gente viver mas a atual que a gente
vivo é economia atual a economia de
consumo que um do seu mais importante
dessa economia é o preço e não se deve
estar se perguntando o que define o
preço é bem simples quem descobriu isso
foi adam smith o primeiro economista
conhecido por muito pouco pelo pai da
economia
não tínhamos ficou que o preço é o
equilíbrio entre oferta que quem quer
vender pelo maior preço ea demanda quem
quer comprar pelo menor preço em
diferentes lojas você pode encontrar o
mesmo produto entrou em em influências
diferentes como você pode ver aqui na
loja 2 tem um tablets por 399 reais
enquanto na loja quanto têm o mesmo
tablets por seiscentos e noventa e dois
reais e noventa e um centavos então em
com o mesmo produto em diferentes lojas
você pode economizar mais de cem reais a
economia de consumo gera bem-estar porém
o consumo excessivo gera problemas
como você pode ver aqui nas imagens essa
garota está comprando tudo que vê pela
frente coitado do marido gasta todo o
dinheiro que ganha no trabalho as
pessoas economizam e compram aqui aquilo
que não precisam por exemplo eu eu gosto
aquele sapato vou comprar nem pense é
necessário crianças quando ganhei de
aniversário
logo basta uma intenção que vão comprar
as fábricas consomem recursos naturais
que não desfilava por exemplo esse
tapete e madeira que será que ela foi
usada direito foi pegar a d de um lugar
que podia pegar madeira
então olha em volta de sua casa onde
você está
veja aqui não foi mesmo precisar dosar
com recursos naturais
eu gosto de dinheiro que eu ganhei de
aniversário escolhi direito e com o que
eu preciso solução consumo consciente
o consumo consciente faz com que a
economia só tenha benefício
minha dica é pesquisar o preço é uma boa
opção para o elenco começar a economizar
e você o que você faça economizar pense
bem